so now let's talk about the actual
report okay Donald Trump's Attorney
General William Barr is going to send
the Robert Muller report first to Donald
Trump before the House of
Representatives gets to look at it this
is according not to left-wing media but
according to a Republican senator named
Lindsey Graham from South Carolina it's
gonna work out perfectly okay anything
Donald Trump doesn't want being seen by
the house and potentially made public he
can redact and claim executive privilege
over Lindsey Graham also now says that
it's expected to take weeks to get a
version of the Moller report that would
be acceptable to trump to have made
public which is absolutely ridiculous
Congress should get the full unredacted
report they can analyze it they can
determine what is genuinely sensitive
information in terms of national
security and the House of
Representatives would be able to decide
about its release you could go to the
FBI the FBI would be a totally
reasonable agency to consult about what
is in the report that would actually
pose a national security threat
it can't be opted up to trump okay this
is the continuation sort of the next
phase in what we can call a slow-motion
cover-up everything has been telegraphed
in advance the selection and the
appointment of William burrows attorney
general who doesn't even believe a
president can be charged with
obstruction the summary of a summary
carefully worded and published by
William Barr weeks now for Donald Trump
to pick and choose what he does and
doesn't want released and Trump's own
attorney general is going to allow Trump
who is the subject of the investigation
to redact the report about the
investigation into him Trump will get to
edit the report before it goes public
now I'm not saying that no redactions
would likely be necessary if there are
pieces of information in there that
relate to intelligence assets or methods
and sources okay for national security
reasons we should redact that the FBI is
well-positioned to make that call the
House of Representatives is
well-positioned to make that call if it
relates to open
investigations which there are many at
this point okay the FBI in the house can
figure out what shouldn't be published
but hat you can't let the guy being
investigated decide what does and
doesn't get published about the
investigation into him
yeah it's called executive privilege and
it certainly is a privilege not only can
trump redact information he also had the
opportunity to fire people conducting
the investigation over the past year and
a half luckily he didn't fire Muller but
he could have I guess our only recourse
if he does decide to do this would be
potentially the house subpoenaing the
full report or them calling Muller and
William Barr to testify before Congress
with those testimonies be held in
private or in public
probably in private if there's a lot of
national security information that's too
sensitive to release but yeah we got to
see the full report I mean come on this
this is ridiculous the only hope is the
White House is known to be so
incompetent and inept that maybe they
would mess up or the redactions and not
end up redacting everything that might
actually give us a window into what the
full scope of the investigation has been
here's my call to you are any of the
trumpets in our audience willing to
admit that Donald Trump redacting his
own investigation is ridiculous it's not
transparent it's not sensible you don't
need to tell me that you no longer
support Trump you don't need to tell me
that you like Hillary Clinton or whoever
all I'm asking is are there trumpets out
there who are willing to say it's not
the right thing for Trump to redact the
report into his own investigation that's
all I'm asking let me know I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show one of
today's David Pakman show sponsors is
simple habit an app that provides a
massive library of really excellent five
minute guided meditations they're
letting everybody in our audience use it
completely free for one week when you go
to simple habit comm slash Pakman we've
talked a lot on the program about the
growing scientific evidence pointing to
the benefits of meditation and what
really sets simple habit apart is the
variety of guided meditations that they
offer more than 2,000 made
for many different issues that you may
be dealing with if you need help falling
asleep if you have anxiety that you're
dealing with if you want to be more
productive during the day they have
meditation specifically tailored for
certain times of day like when you're
waking up or your commute to work or
when you've just gotten home from work
I'm a huge advocate of meditation myself
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day and each meditation
takes just five minutes and they're very
easy to follow maybe you want to feel
more grounded before you start your day
at work or at school maybe you want to
keep your mind a little more clear so
that it's easier to accomplish your
goals or you just want a calmer more
peaceful experience throughout your day
simple habit can help you get there it
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app it's available on
Android iOS and web browser and you can
try it completely free for a week check
it out go to simple habit comm slash
Pakman I've put a link down below
underneath the video